your non solo I mother killer I am not
what they say the parables your knee I
am lost promiscuous vamp I'm not violent
aletta i'm done with this respect life
and not of these things do not belong to
me and I didn't do not they said I've
done no no hija I have not key on door I
have not raped don't I have not stolen
anything I'd hola no no not a doctor I
wasn't there I was not present to the
crime I used to share of my life on
merit especially with Meredith's own I
mean we had a strong friendship Lyoko
bothered you would have she used to
worry lavoro about me when I when I was
going to work and she was always very
kind to me Meredith better with cheese
Mary that was killed remember I not let
you see fit I've always wanted justice
for her you know for delivery time
escaping from the truth and I'll never
will and I've never done that I'll
insist and insists to want the truth to
come out I've never hurt anybody never
in my life the Coosa game is at the most
recontra I'm the deer cheese asian
people yummy bash some ways wassup yeah
simply superb insult dog is it a bit
important more than the accusation that
was pending on me all those years I
always thought that everything was going
to be one was going to be fist and in a
very little time on the contrary but you
know little like this didn't happen the
woodwork
when I had to support that and that I
first and just situation and to go on
day by day c'mon year alone in Cabo as
if i was living in a nightmare my own is
beautiful and as if I couldn't wake up